let's talk about permissions when each
app apk is installed it's given its own
unique Linux user ID and each app runs
within into an instance of the Android
virtual machine as a result each app is
completely sandboxed its files processes
and other resources are inaccessible to
other apps this sandboxing approach is
used to ensure that by default no app
can access sensitive data or perform
actions that could adversely impact
other apps the OS or user's things like
accessing the internet getting your
users location or reading it or
modifying the contacts database rather
than asking the user each time an app
tries to access something sensitive you
declare missions that your app requires
in its manifest you can get a list of
all of the permissions your app may
require here at the Android developer
site so why not just ask for all the
permissions and never worry about it
again
well when users install your app they're
greeted with this dialog which lists all
the permissions that you've requested
along with the more user friendly
descriptions nothing says this app was
built by hackers who want to steal my
data robbed my house clear up my bank
account and taken share nude pictures of
me like a weather app that wants access
to every permission on the device best
practice is to request the absolute
minimum of permissions every time you
need to request a new permission take it
as a flag to stop and consider if there
are other alternatives that might
achieve the same goal for example using
an intent to launch the camera app
rather than accessing the camera
directly later we'll look at ways to
share your data with other apps using
intents and content providers to create
bridges between these apps and boxes you
can declare and use those permissions in
these instances to similarly restrict
access to sensitive information